[Music]
now i'm on a hot line over here
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'm sick oh you mean the ting
when i get rid of something with my
fingers no that's flick
i'm sick do you mean when
i'm trying to shoot a basketball when it
hits off the rim
nah that's a brick i'm sick
oh you mean when you're out in like an
absolute knob head no
that's prick i'm sick i'm neat
you mean the stuff that you do with your
knife and fork nah that's
eat i'm neat
you mean the ting that you take out the
wrapper
no that's sweet i'm neat
do you think do you mean the thing you
do with your chick in the bedroom
[Laughter]
nah that's cheat that's not what i was
thinking ah
why was that the first thing that what
are you saying
my mom said cheap
bro i was looking at your face like
you did
no that's true
i was thinking because i was thinking
beat didn't even come close to my hair
yeah i was thinking
the thing i do with my girl in the
bedroom so i was looking at your face
like
are you sure but
let the cards land where they've made
bro let's go
all right say less that's hilarious
i'll i'll slap that one go for g
oh i'm hot white as it is
man said no that's cheat
that's too funny that's too funny all
right
i'm high i think we did that one already
yeah we didn't get anywhere with it oh
yeah to be fair
that's jokes um do you think do you mean
that blue thing in the
up there up there nah that's the sky i'm
high
oh you mean the thing the warm dessert
with blueberries no that's
pie i'm high
do you mean the thing you do when you're
waving
nah that's goodbye okay i'm high
so you're a double agent no my g that's
spy
i'm high do you mean when
i can't think bro i can't think bro
man the man are screaming score my name
is screaming
why is that right screaming where's the
ramen she's not coming to me
i'm vexed it's called you do you want me
to go by myself where you're pouring
that
i'll go so you think you're a double
agent now that's spy
i'm high what the thing that you're
tossing in the pan now that's fry
i'm high oh when you think you're acting
a little bit sneaky now that's sly
i'm high
oh when you say when the end is near no
no no that's nigh
i'm high oh you were that annoying bug
around the room now that's fly
i'm high you're nervous to speak to
people now that's shy
i'm high fair play
[ __ ] play but that's a lie
right i'm a bed
do you mean the thing that happens to
your stomach when you're very full
now that's fed i'm a bed
you mean the thing that you push through
the snow my g
that's a sled i'm bed i'm a bed
do you mean the thing that lives lives
that's holding up your neck
that's holding up your neck that's a
head
i'm a bed the wooden box in my back
garden
that's a shed i'm a bed
do you mean the thing i can't think bro
i can't think under pressure like this i
can't think under pressure like this
stop all right fair play [ __ ] me
that's hilarious i got me sweaty bro
that's hilarious
that's a good brain teaser that's a good
i feel like doing stuff like that is a
good
ice breaker slash a good brain exercise
to you know
get the juices flowing get your blood
pressure i like that i enjoy that
yeah man yeah man should do something
like that we'll do impromptu improv
i'm just going to start an episode with
it one time i
panicked i wanna know you would panic
and freeze that i can't think under
pressure like this
i can't think under pressure like
my this but i'm in bed oh that's
hilarious bro
[ __ ] me that made me laugh oh jesus
christ under pressure like this
this is a lot of [ __ ] that reminds me of
the time
when we were in the car and i said let's
do some role play
i'm a random guest at a party and i ask
you what your job is and you have to
make up on the spot
and i gave you time to think
and you were like okay go and i was like
cool what do you do for a living you
you froze i said i can't i can't
i couldn't do it food it was the
funniest thing
that was the funniest thing of all time
let's try it now then [ __ ] it
um all right cool so we're at a party
we're at dinner party wait
and you're you're you're an undercover
agent okay
and you need to make up a job on the
spot yeah
of what you do and i'm going to ask you
questions about that job and you need to
answer me
and making me believe that that's your
job okay
ready tell me when you're ready actually
i'm not going to put pressure on you
can i learn a little bit of pressure on
you
what rhythm are you ready
cause i'm ready if you man don't know
about pretty ricky pretty ricky
pretty ricky ricky in the back bro if i
was a r b singer i would have been i
would have been one of these man
no hug are you ready
making love to the mic cause i'm ready
gonna be a little bit pressure on you
cause you know i want it
and i need it
[Music]
bro pleasure p was in it yeah he made
ricky he 100 he had to go solo these men
were
any leeches you know they couldn't
string eight bars together
and they they were they were making cake
nah i said next verse after that was
where's your name girl
where you're from are you alone can i
come chill with you
i ain't a bugaboo i would say
and this is too much i'm gonna bargain
man said what was his name blue ivy or
some [ __ ]
blue star please stop
by me man was always had his breasts out
that's all he had gone blue star
i can't remember the other two
spectacular spectacular
experience wanted like he had like dr
that's a dress like plats
and there was one more i can't remember
his name spectacular was the one that
was beating that yeah in the elevator
spectacular was the mess was it or was
that the other one so
no speck was the one that always had his
top off i believe oh
i believe blue star was the main guy
sexy spare yeah blue star was the main
third like the one that always went
first obviously was a singer
speck was the one that always had a
shirt off and the third guy currently oh
it's
um he used to say his name all the time
it's um
i'm gonna have to google it what was his
name bro it was like um
that's hilarious that's [ __ ]
hilarious
uh what they call pretty ricky
the bear with the dress was an absolute
state
he looked like he was on crack always
um baby blue
yeah yeah speck yeah slick em slick em
high flick
slick of a pleasure man he was a
crackhead he looked like he was
um he looked like little wayne and
flavor flavor how do you
that's slicker that makes per melt it's
like a mine
you keep saying hi he said it in a song
no it's like
sexy specular
[Music]
[Laughter]
what a chew bang someone needs to bring
back pretty really oh late night special
that was the album that was an album a
late night special
what an app 2006 2005. um
sorry sorry came out 2007. um
[Music]
that was a bang of home if you heard
that in the last 45 minutes of a climate
dance
you best secure a wine i was live if
that song came on and i had no one to
whine bro
i was so [ __ ] angry bro banger
it made me feel like i should have asked
the dj what's your set list dude yeah
because if someone i know
if anybody ricky's heading up i need to
patent someone early early bro because
if i ain't got a wine
for a hotline then why am i here why am
i here what a tune
oh what a tune yo
you man i know you meant a young if you
appreciate
r b old school rms old school r b
pretty ricky hotline yeah you're gonna
want to smash
you're going to want to do one of those
ones
[Music]
they're
taking granny patties off and put a song
on
oh man said he's not willing to beat you
naked
put the thong on sexy suspect was a
chauvinist
oh bro wow that's funny taking granny
panties i can put a thumb down
what a tune what i love the sexy tone
that make the dick long
yo pretty ricky was it they were on crud
24 7. they got too much
pum in their heyday they did in their
heyday
they got too much porn thrown at them
that's what thrown at them slickerman
was banging one yet in a
elevator did you see that no he recorded
himself s
backshotting someone in the elevator it
went on world style sighting oh is it
yeah i may have seen it at the time but
i don't know what you see is my man
piping her
it looks like any amateur pawn yeah yeah
banging her in the end of her back shot
and then he looks up in the mirror just
kidding t
the shade's still on looks up in the
room in the elevator
just cause it's smiling
that probably ended the whole time yeah
yeah yeah that's hello you can't be
banging yet
on camera bro shade's still on you know
oh pretty
ricky they fell into money i don't know
who funded them
but literally someone must have caught
pleasure p singing at a wedding or
something
i said i have to sign you yeah man i
said it's it's me and the gang always no
no one
then three years in for me he'd had
enough of their [ __ ] oh and he went
solely bam
he must have so many people telling him
like why are you
in this group it's like
man that used to go to x factor and then
simon would be like you're sick
you man are trash yeah yeah if you want
to make it in this competition you need
to ditch them like and they come
backstage like i don't know what to do i
don't know what to do
like you know what to do you know you're
just a tough choice fan when simon says
ditch them man
knows best bro and then they never even
made it to judges houses bro
it was live they were livid they burnt
all their bridges
and they didn't even make it to judges
houses
ah bro x factor was savage
oh my goodness that's hilarious um
but yeah hilarious yeah someone told the
pleasure bee must have had
man or man or man saying why are you in
this group playboy yeah
it doesn't make any sense just doesn't
it doesn't make any sense
what are you doing what are you actually
doing
[ __ ] me that's hilarious that is
hilarious
i'm so glad we went out i didn't even
know how did the pleasure even come back
what were you singing
peer pressure because you were thinking
about the thing yeah i was like yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah you once said it wasn't
fish
that's too funny bro all up lips
bro when we do our first live show man
would be like yeah yeah we're essega
and this is going to be a spot what like
if i'm seven minutes in this one i'm
gonna be confused
it's gonna be all laughs
and then the last died out and i'm just
in my zone bro and what's going on
everyone's coffee like
yeah okay what is going on when does the
joke end
and i'm just there like in it
just d'angelo have in your way
and everybody have to take a breath
[Music]
licking it and if you're happy
i can provide
where the [ __ ] is foo had what is going
on
i'd take it to the point [ __ ] is for
your head i take it to the point where
these men are so confused vivid
livid and confused bro and just as
they're about to walk out
i was only playing all right we're here
we're here we're here um
but yeah all right back in the zone but
yeah dinner party
secret agent wow i'm hot you need to
sell me on your your employment
otherwise i'm going to start
asking questions yeah you're going to be
plucking holes out there say let's say
let's say that right let me know when
you're ready
ready i've not got anything in my head
but i'm ready all right
what's going on are you good i'm good
bro what are you saying chilling g
chillin man i hate all this shmoozy
boozy [ __ ] what do you mean
just these dinner parties man this is
like networking [ __ ] i'm just not a
buyer man yeah i know i know yeah
i don't i don't i hate network i hate
the term networking
i hate the concept i hate the fact that
you have to like it's not who you know
it's not what you who you know yeah
[Music]
i work hard man you hear me what do i do
i'm an accountant g
okay okay for who
um j m lewis j m lewis yeah j and lewis
and partners
okay okay how long have you been there
bro i started there
james lewis so you're doing the james
himself yeah managing dee
managing director nice to meet you roski
nice to meet you bro i'm an affiliate
bro
an affiliate affiliate bro what is that
[Laughter]
oh
let me pull it back let me breathe man
yo hang on hang on right
i'm not gonna lie to you that's the
first thing that came to my head bro
what what the [ __ ] does that mean do you
know what do you know why i'm so annoyed
no i'm so annoyed because i don't know
why i ask you what you do because when
you
when you were going to ask me i was
going to say an accountant oh really
mother's life that's the [ __ ]
i stole it you stole it from me so the
next a was affiliate
and i don't even know what it means big
man what am i affiliated with drugs
gangs
rock and roll i don't know yeah i don't
know
bro
[Laughter]
james i don't know i'm sweating
uncontrollably and i don't know what i'm
affiliated oh my god
oh my god i'm not here for improv oh my
god
you're the funniest person i've ever met
i'm sweating uncontrollably
same fam
[Laughter]
yo yo stop
all right let me breathe man let's move
the [ __ ] on bro
oh let's move the [ __ ] on
oh jesus christ
i'm sweating guys
like subscribe comment make some friends
in the comments please build
relationship bonds foundations
i'm sure we've been chat for half an
hour fam we've been in it
ah patreon oh my goodness [ __ ] me
oh my goodness guys if you're not on
patreon your mission you're missing out
on 50
of the content oh my goodness get on
over to patreon episodes every single
thursday every thursday without fail
head on over to patreon
patreon.com forward slash shits and gigs
we love you guys oh my goodness and
without further ado we've got through
has fun facts
right jesus oh my stomach man said i'm
an affiliate
what does that even mean man what does
that even mean james
oh my god oh my god i
i can't comprehend how confused i was
when you said that
i thought ra he's going in he's trying
to throw me way off the center balls
wrong
way off the scent oh my god i couldn't
even finish my sentence and asking you
what the [ __ ] is that
i was gonna a mother's life i was gonna
say an account i'm sorry bro
i was going to say an account and you
stole it i'm sorry bro i have nothing
left
i hate how good i am a lion that's what
annoys me as well
i must say jm lewis i'm james lewis
who man said you're the james lewis
from the accounting firm
the world renowned accounting firm oh
oh my goodness that's too funny man whoa
right the fun fact of the day is on um
november 8th 2017 a young chinese man
named wu
young ning tried to pull off tried to do
pull-ups
on the side of a 60's two-story building
and it's the last decision he ever made
so he was an internet
um a terrifying stunt man so he climbed
up a
building and he was meant to
like i said he was meant to be doing
pull-ups on it and he gained millions of
followers and blah blah blah
by the time of his death he had 62. he
had 300 000 followers
okay but when he fell from a he fell
from a 62-story skyscraper in china
but he didn't drop immediately like to
the ground he apparently landed on like
a terrorist or something
but he was meant to propose to his wife
i think a week later so he was raising
funds
that's the reason why i was doing all
these stunts wow raising funds for
engagement ring for an engagement ring
to propose to his wife like the week
after and his wife confirmed that he had
passed away
which is was in 2017. so he was a stunt
man who rose to fame by scaling and
skating places and doing um stunts and
stuff yeah
and that was the last thing the thing is
i hate that had to be him
bro but someone needed to die from all
this [ __ ] for someone to realize that
this ain't the way
to go yeah when i'm on instagram and
[ __ ] and these men
are hanging off cliffs doing all this
foolishness no
stop stop fam and the thing is it's so
popular now
that you ain't even gonna get famous
from it i don't even
when i see the videos i didn't even
check to see who the guy doing it is
i don't even check to see who that guy
is i just move the [ __ ] on with my life
i kiss my teeth and i scroll up
and say these men are foolish i don't
even think that the person
it doesn't even cross my mind that the
person that's doing it is a is a guy
that does this
do i mean i just look at it and think
[ __ ] hell and then just scroll up
mm-hmm
so this needs to stop it for one it's a
saturated market
number two we didn't even check for you
we scroll up
so if you if you're a stunt guy and
you're looking for fame bro
pick another pick something else yeah
man because it ain't worth it man
high risk high reward but high risk bro
fam there's more risk than there is
rewards are you seeing the man that
climb up those towers you know the ones
with like
minimal tilt uh nah nah nah nah no then
once like it's like
not even a tower like it looks like a
[ __ ] like a radio [ __ ] thing okay
and it's got like an antenna at the top
okay and they're like hanging off the
antenna
and they're looking down and you think
how did you even get up there i'm not
it's not even like a building you can
climb up oh it's like a [ __ ]
eiffel tower yeah one of them looking
things but like real skinny
bro i see them and i'm like what are you
thinking
what are you actually thinking speaking
of did you see that right there's a
random tick tock going around the other
day
one guy that maybe got struck by
lightning in a swimming pool did you see
it
no fam there's a guy filming himself
it's pouring down with rain pouring down
with rain
and he's got pulled in his back garden
and he goes with his um
like gopro and he's like bro i love
swimming when it's when it's this kind
of weather
and he jumps off
to jump into the pool and as he's in the
air
lightning strikes his swimming pool and
then he lands
no [ __ ] way swear to god man would
have
he would have died immediately he would
have died immediately
oh my god he's this close to jumping in
like getting in the pool he's like here
bro i'm surprised he didn't send that
and then he's
in secret and then he's just he jumps he
falls in
to be fair i see so much shocking [ __ ]
on tick tock i don't know what to say
that reminds me of um there was a tick
tock
um it was a guy that was doing he's a
fan of naruto and he was doing like a
chidori
like sighting and it was raining outside
but he was just recording himself the
obviously the background music's there
but it was raining outside but as soon
as he did it
lightning struck wow and he looks back
like oh my god this is [ __ ] sick bro
that is sick like what are the odds and
it looks incredible
that sounds [ __ ] incredible that
sounds sick there's a girl that does
hand signs have you seen it
maybe but i've probably like an asian
girl she does it like she gets in like
full makeup and there's like
a split screen of like her there's like
her here in like a black room
and she's just doing it and then she'll
pull up like different naruto scenes
like rotating through and one would be
like kakashi versus zabazar
and then they'll be like sasuke doing
some [ __ ] and even when um
do you remember when sasuke was using
naruto to do like
his hand signs i don't remember no he
was like beef in naruto
okay and then he'd like grab his arm and
then do like a hand sign
and then beef him again and then do like
another one it was sick she was even
doing like single-handed ones bro
she's sick then things there are just
things i'm
gang guesting is just these are two
gangs
it's too live [ __ ] it's sick
naruto is staple
staple anime i hate the fact that it
doesn't get it obviously
gets the top three it gets a lot of
credit but true true anime fans
are like oh it's too commercial do you
know what i mean it's too commercial
like they don't check for them once
which i can understand but when you it's
actually
unbelievably good it's as famous as it
is because it's so
good of course once we start entering
like the akatsky bits
you're like this show is is the is the
one
it gives them song it's insane it's dark
bro naruto is the one man
i'm so happy i i jumped on when i jumped
on same g
[ __ ] even early days when um around a
time where
sasuke versus like orochimaru when he
gets his first curse mark in the trees
in their tuning exams and he uh he's
just recently unlocked his um
sharing gun i think this is when he gets
his second uh
yeah yeah because he gets the first one
in like the tuning exams early days
and he gets the second one because he
then is copying rock lee because rocky
challenges him in it
and rockley tries the lotus thing and
then he clocks it
and then when he's scrapping he does the
loadings
that now what the [ __ ] how how how how
how literally how
um but then when he's fighting rochimaru
in the forest he gets his second one i'm
sure
and he's putting on he's putting arms on
the road tomorrow he's doing all the
fire jutsu mad and they change
you know what's going on when they
change the animation style bros when
they one when they change their
animation style and two when they change
the
opening credits music yeah yeah every
time they change the music i'm thinking
something's popping yeah yeah yeah we've
made a development
fam you and you have to watch the
opening credits and you have to watch
the closing credits because you have to
see
it tells you bro you see different
powers you see different characters
yeah bro this is this is where i'm up to
in
um remember i told you my hero in the
previous episode of episode before
my hero um is part one part two tactic
so i'm on a part two now so the music
has changed where am i you're not there
yet
so and it's just you just know it's
gonna pop second season
second half of this season yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's gonna pop bro yeah yeah
oh i'm so sorry guys i know you guys
don't i know somebody 87
of you don't want channels don't [ __ ]
with anime but clearly we do
hence the reason why i talk about it
quite often but you guys need i was in
your shoes guys
the guys that don't watch anime the
eight seven percent of you that don't
try to make i was in your shoes 11 12
years ago bro
trust me just watch one watch the
trailer watch the first
episode of death note and then come chat
to me tell me i'm wrong
yeah bro tell me it's not [ __ ]
addictive yeah bro it's unreal because
that's how i got bella into
anime bella never used to watch anime
bella watch one episode of anime one
episode of death
note rap she's now watching hunter rex
santa she was watching baruto when i
used to watch bruto
she was watching um she watched a couple
of episodes of my hero she watched a
couple episodes of she watched
vin lan saga through and through with me
vin lasagna's sick she was
first lockdown she watched the whole
villain sagging thorin and denman there
i was gonna say you've never even spoke
to me about villains
i'm surprised i didn't at the time i'm
sorry i don't know i was preaching it
for time
yeah so i'm surprised you've watched the
whole thing you didn't even tell me i'm
the thing is i can't remember you
preaching it to me but i'm sure you were
the one that recommended it to me
100 yeah i recommended you when i was
like one episode in oh is it
yeah yeah i saw it on comments on our um
youtube recommendations so we watched it
during lockdown and
bro who is what's the prayers name that
actually um doppy thought dawfin's dad
what's his name i can't remember i've
watched in ages because he
is arms yeah he has values
yeah as much as as much as he was like
the antagonist of the show
uh his core values bro this is one this
is one of the main reasons why i love
anime
it teaches you so much stuff about life
bro
and people don't understand because it's
animated they think oh it's childish
but if you actually deep what they say
and how they actually
put pieces together it's ah
it's it unravels a new world it changes
the way you think about stuff
yeah man and this is the reason why i
love anime yeah yeah yeah because
it taps into things that you thought
weren't possible yeah
[Music]
bro oh i love anime i love that amazing
um but what you got for me today
speaking of anime japan tokyo olympics
okay um olympics
um obviously i've been watching the
olympics first of all i'm pretty sure
i'm one of three people watching the
olympics right now
i'm not watching it at all no one's
watching it because it's like a clock
no it's not is it not no it's not is it
not
bro bbc iplayer you go on
freeview on your tv bbc iplayer it tells
you what day they're on
they they're they're patterning it for
us this this time
it's literally got day one day two day
three you click on whatever day you want
and it tells you do you want to watch
this event this event this event
and if it's live it would say do you
want to watch it live or do you want to
start from the beginning okay
bro you can watch whatever you want and
there's more time like obviously
i do a lot of um late shifts so when i
come home from work sometimes and i'm
just chilling or whatever come home put
the tv on it says olympics 2020 live
and that's at like 2 a.m and i'm like
yeah okay fair play but now
they're running in japan they're running
it all day bro
they start because i was watching the
skateboard the other day and they're
like oh yeah
bro they've got first year they've ever
got skateboarding in it these might have
gotten off
it's already finished but you can still
watch on day two you've got an eye
player live
um i was watching skateboarding and it
was they were saying i was like
8am here in tokyo and i'm thinking right
you meant i'm running at 8 00 a.m
um but they just run it all day bro but
yeah skateboarding like 8 am by the way
i've never had friends i'm not breakfast
fam when he said it's 8 a.m that's
exactly word for word what i said i said
i'm not skateboarding
if i'm a skateboarder i want to live
chill yeah
i'm not skateboarding at 8am you can't
make me
if you want that gold [ __ ] bro 8 a.m
but um basically what i was gonna say is
for one i don't think anyone's watching
the olympics which breaks my heart
no it breaks my heart because bro i have
been an advocate for the olympics my
whole life
same same when i was a little kid i
loved the olympics
with the olympics sorry to cut you off
we will get back to you about but i
think one of the main reasons why i'm
not
engulfed in as much i saw the opening
ceremony or like maybe
and worst opening ceremony hour of it
but because there's no fans or there's
no spectacles it takes everything away
from
everything away from me and it's like so
depressing damn bro yeah so depressing
these men are all coming out with their
countries and then we're like there's no
one there bro
are you waving that it's a shame it's a
massive [ __ ] it sucks it's because tokyo
is in like
a state of emergency right now oh what
is it bro apparently they did a survey
and it's like 58
of japanese people are opposed to the
olympics
so the majority of people in japan want
the electrics cancelled
really just to because they're they're
they're they're suffering in japan right
now wow
okay i have nothing suffering in japan
right now they've got cases for the roof
okay so they're in a like what they call
a state of emergency okay
in japan right now and then the olympics
rolls through
there's 11 000 athletes in the olympics
so there's 11 000 extra people from
every country in the world
in tokyo right now not including their
coaches
or their family whoever else they
brought out with them uh physios
whatever
yeah yeah yeah commentators cameramen
all these people thousands upon
thousands but thousands of people are
all
centralized in their capital city right
now whilst they're suffering
like the most they've suffered with
kovid so i'm not surprised that people
are like
are you joking this can't run
but that side i was watching the um
naomi osaka doki series on netflix okay
do you know who she is yeah the tennis
player of course ted
she did the she did the fire tv she did
the fighting ceremony
yeah yeah so she's got a three-part
series on netflix
okay banging okay banging
and there's a few bits that stuck out
there's two bits of stuck out for me
that are deep
and we've had a funny episode and i
don't want to kill the buzz but i think
it's interesting
i'm in i'm i'm here um
so basically you watch it and it talks
about what
i meant i'm an affiliate i said what am
i
an affiliate for drugs alcohol rock and
roll
too funny here that's too funny i'm so
sorry
oh [ __ ] i might say bro at the end i'm
an affiliate bro
[Music]
my head was doing loops like an amazon
affiliate
like what are you talking about let me
break the chat oh my days
um yeah sorry netflix blah blah blah
yeah yeah yeah
so the first thing which is dread as
it's going through because it's real
time
like the thing ends the final episode is
in 2021
yeah yeah okay so um it follows her
through like
her highs and lows and stuff like that
um and the first bit there's two like
really sad bits the first one obviously
so
for context if you don't know who naomi
osaka is
she's a professional tennis player she
is half japanese half haitian
both her parents are immigrants from
obviously their respective countries
and she and they moved to america when
she was three i think she was born in
she was one in japan
and she moved to us when she was three
her in the system
what a mix by the way
and japanese bro yeah mad mad
[ __ ] i love [ __ ] like that yeah same i
love [ __ ] like that
so anyway she's professional tennis
player she's won the
australian open and i think she's won
the u.s open twice now i think i might
be getting them mixed
up but she's top um first time she won
the u.s open she'd be
in no australian open all us open i
can't remember she beat serena williams
for it mm-hmm
i remember that one i can't remember
which one it was but i do remember that
yeah yeah was
really scratchy with her blah blah i
remember i remember it was our first
grandson
yeah so anyway it talks about kind of
the pressures and
stuff 17 or something stupid like that
she was young yeah yeah yeah sorry
caught you off by the way so um it talks
about that and the first and she had a
really close relationship with kobe
bryant
okay so she was really good friends with
kobe bryant okay and during the donkey
series
it goes through kobe bryant's death okay
so
this peak so basically her relationship
with kobe bryant was basically him
taking like a mental role
for her in just dealing with the
pressures of being a superstar basically
a young superstar and what everything
that comes with it with that
and how you can continue to perform at a
higher level
with all this pressure so that she would
come to kobe and say oh i'm struggling
with this i'm struggling with this
psychologically like
how do you deal with this and how do you
deal with this like i want that mamba
mentality kind of thing
and he would obviously help and when he
died she was broken
she lost tournaments when when he died
she was she was broken and they
interviewed her
and they asked her how she's feeling on
the day on the day that he died
they asked her they interviewed her by
it because obviously everyone knew that
she had a good relationship with him
and fam oh my god it was so sad it
resonated with me
in a way sometimes that i'll explain but
yeah obviously the first point was kobe
he died and then
they said to her like how you feeling
stuff like that she was crying and she
said
i feel like i'm betraying his legacy and
i feel like a failure
because he spends all his time whenever
i
go to him for help he spends so much
time with me
coaching me through this and i come to
him and say how do you deal with this
psychologically
and how do you deal with that
psychologically and all of this stuff
and she's like he tells me but
i'm so weak mentally that i don't
implement it
i'm not mentally strong enough to take
the advice he's given me
and implementing it i'm just weak
but i don't tell him that i'm not
implementing it because i'm too
embarrassed
and she just lost a match uh i think
she'd lost round one of the us open
she just lost round one of the us open
she was out
in either round one around two but she
was still in the rounds no quarterfinals
sammy's nothing she was still in the six
around
16 rounds and she got kicked out and she
typed a text to him
to say how do you deal with this kind of
thing and she said
the reason i lost is because i'm not
taking the advice he's given me because
i'm so mentally weak
and i've just lost and i typed him a
text asking how to deal with it
but i was too ashamed to send it because
the whole reason i've lost
is because i'm mentally weak because i
don't have the mamba mentality
that's why i lost yeah i lost because
i'm not i don't have mother mentality
and that's why i'm lost yeah so once
i've lost
i typed him a text but i was too
embarrassed to send it yeah
so i never sent it and now he's dead
and i'll never speak to him again i will
never get any advice from him again
and he could this is the lowest point in
my career
and i was too embarrassed to contact my
friend
and now i'll never speak to him again
and i'll never be able to press send
i'll net
that text was still typed and i will
never be able to present
bro i wanted to cry for her i actually
wanted to cry for her
because especially when she said i was
embarrassed because
he's given me all this advice and i'm
not implementing it yeah i felt
it resonated with me in a way
because i don't ask people for advice
they give it to me and i don't implement
it but i
a lot of the time i actually stick in a
dark turn not dark turn but like a
serious turn
obviously i act
so positive all the time
that certain people relate that to me
you know what i mean certain people
think like when they're feeling down
they turn to me make sense and they're
struggling with like our friends
obviously we have friends that want
are trying to achieve certain things and
i have friends that aren't in our
immediate circle that are trying to
achieve certain things and
not that we've achieved anything really
but they
look at what we're doing and they'll
contact me and say bro
i want to do this i want to do that and
i'm struggling with this and that and
i'll hit him up and just black bro i
won't say obviously mama mentality but
i'm like bro it's all about men it's all
about where your head's at like
granted you don't want to do it
sometimes you don't want to do it but
you just got to wake up
[ __ ] open your laptop and start doing
it and once you start doing it just keep
doing it once you keep doing it you just
do it and do it and do it
and don't stop doing it i've got the
itchiest nose [ __ ] hell
[ __ ] me sorry sorry but once you
just do it you just keep doing it and
keep doing it and keep doing it and
before you know it you're done
and before you know if you keep doing it
you'll get yourself in a position where
you have to do it
that's like where where we're at we have
to do we don't have a choice anymore
yeah yeah so now i don't need motivation
to do it yeah because i ain't got a
choice
yeah just like work you make it your
work and once it's your work because
you're not motivated to go
to work every day but you do it anyway
you've got no choice so you put yourself
in a position where motivation isn't a
factor anymore
and that's when you'll succeed and i'll
chat all this
yeah i'm working to quit my job yeah i'm
working to quit my job grinding grinding
grinding
yes quit my job all these
congratulations messages like well done
well done well done well done well done
and it's like i'm too embarrassed to
tell them sometimes that i wake up so
depressed
that i can't even bear to open my laptop
i can't physically bear it and i do it
but like i'm ashamed because i'm not
motivated to do it and like stuff like
gym like all this stuff like we're
talking about like
tighten up tighten up summer edition
like yeah summer merch all this stuff
bro sometimes i'm just like [ __ ] the gym
yeah i'm not going
and i see one guess exactly but they
turn to me to be the guy because i don't
do that
yeah and sometimes i do do it but i'm
too ashamed to tell them that
bro yesterday i didn't go yeah i'm a
human being i'm a human being yesterday
i didn't [ __ ] go
and i'm ashamed of it and today i'm
going but
i don't tell them that because i don't
want to demotivate them more
yeah and when she was saying all that
stuff i was like [ __ ]
that [ __ ] resonates even though it's
different it [ __ ] resonates
okay because she was so embarrassed
saying like help me help me help me
oh his help his help he's up she's like
thank you thank you thank you
then she wins a couple more tournaments
and she's like mama mentality when
really
it's all fake it's all fake because
behind closed doors she's just as
insecure as she was in the first place
and then she was so embarrassed to turn
to him because this was the point where
she she knew that he knew you ain't mom
but [ __ ]
like but obviously he wouldn't have said
that yeah he would have still been there
for him yeah of course he would have
written in her corner for sure yeah and
he could have possibly shared
moments like what you think is my
mentality all the time
i'm full of [ __ ] amount of times i cried
myself to sleep bro i'm at times i
thought it wasn't good enough yeah yeah
my times are like i will i told everyone
i trained until six in the morning i did
did i [ __ ]
i mean i slept until six and i woke up
and started training yeah you know what
i mean like
everyone's human and then she that's it
the person that she turned to
for that is gone now yeah gone
gone done and i was like [ __ ] that's
deep
[ __ ] that's deep she must have been
hurting yeah man i think so many people
were hurting bro
bro hurting every the whole world was
saying the whole what fam
it was what january february times it's
over a year a year and a half yeah
that's flown by because i the thing is
i remember exactly where i was when i
found out
me too i was in the office at work and
one of my colleagues came in
his name is jordan and he was like oh
have you heard he said it so casually
he's like have you heard oh um kobe
bryant's dead i was like
what he's like yeah he died in
helicopter crash i was like what i sat
up i was like what and because
it's such a random way to die as well
not even that it was just
i'm not like i watch and
somewhat follow basketball but i've
never been a
hardcore baller fan you know but
when it's someone like kobe even if you
don't watch football if david beckham
died it's gonna mean something yeah yeah
yeah do you know what i mean
so it's like how can you just come in
and say that nonchalantly yeah yeah i
was like that's the reason why i
remember exactly where i was and how it
was said and like
bro what do you realize what you're
saying to me yeah
yeah do you know bro i was in office
just chilling i think i was on my lunch
break bro
bro it was kobe bryant's death is the
first time where i
actually understood how
the generation above why the generation
above us acts
when they hear like george michael died
and they're like what are you on about
that makes perfect sense and i'm sitting
i'm thinking i don't give a
[ __ ] about george michael i know yeah i
know you're talking about even when
michael jackson died
i wasn't like what i was like i swear
that's dread yeah
but the whole world was like are you
crazy what do you mean michael jackson
died fam when kobe died i was like what
the [ __ ] are you saying to me i could
have cried
and i don't know why i felt that way but
then i started thinking back
and i remember there's a specific memory
that stuck out to me i used to love kobe
bryant
i was obsessed with kylie brown when i
was a kid you told me before especially
if you told me bro i was obsessed with
brian and i remember for one of my
birthdays one year
my mum said oh what do you want for no
christmas it was christmas what do you
want for christmas
and in jd sport it's when used to be
called jd sport
before jd in jd sport my guy
they were running these nba jeans bro
jeans this is how much i love like i was
so obsessed with basketball
i used to dress like an american when
all my boys were out here playing
football
and they're wearing their [ __ ] vapers
and their total nighties
and just [ __ ] shorts or trackies
tucked into their socks
and all them things i was out here
wearing jordans
baggy jeans like [ __ ] nba jerseys
like i would dress like an american i
didn't give a [ __ ] or any of my friends
said yeah i was obsessed with basketball
yeah i was obsessed with kobe bryant
obsessed and they had these nba
genes so it was just like blue jeans or
black jeans or whatever and it would
have
um a jersey patch so the number on the
genes
sewed into the genie yeah yeah yeah yeah
and they had kobe bryant once
and it was uh eight uh lakers l.a lakers
number eight on there and i saw them one
day it was like in november
and i was like oh my [ __ ] god and
obviously i've told you my mom never
used to buy me [ __ ]
yeah so i saw them i was like oh my god
i could cry i need those jeans bro
before that
there wasn't anything clothing-wise or
anything that i needed
and i was like mom i have to have those
jeans bro
i [ __ ] have to obviously my mum brush
i was like you know i'm not buying them
they were like 50 quid
back then that was 300 quid yeah yeah
yeah i was like mom please i have to i
need those
mom like i was close to tears like mom
please i need the kobe bryant jeans
and um she was like nah nah i'm not
buying i'm not behind that and i was
like [ __ ]
and then obviously a month later she's
like what do you want for christmas and
i said mom please i don't care
anything i don't care about what else
you get me please in jd
those blue um kobe bryant jeans
i have to have them she was like bet i'm
so excited bro so excited christmas day
comes
my mom passes me the present i can feel
his clothing
i could have squealed from tore it open
yeah
tore it open things went everywhere yeah
i look inside
alan iverson black 76ers jeans
i swear to god if i had a match in my
hand i would have dropped it on those
jeans
and i would have dropped on my mum
do you know the [ __ ] thing parents
don't listen sometimes
parents just don't listen they think
that
when a child wants something specific a
substitute is okay
as long as it's like it are you crazy
bro
parents are alan iverson 76ers jeans
number three yeah yeah same thing same
thing yeah box that box that box that
my son will appreciate that anyway bro
i could have set a match to it and my
mom too
bro i was so upset oh i could imagine
worst
christmas ever i can imagine
and i was like and i knew there was no
way i could say to my mom because if i
would say to my mother the [ __ ] i asked
for the lakers she would smack me across
my face
before you finish the set bro on
christmas day before you finish if i'm
picking up chest on christmas day i
would have
nothing you have to be grateful you
wouldn't have had dinner
bro you have to be grateful you can't
run up here talking about what's this
so i had to be like oh and i think she
said oh they didn't have the ones you
wanted so i've got these
i think that's what she said but i was
just like i don't want it in my head i
was like i'm going to kill them
oh yeah i wore them out okay i wore them
more and more i had to
um but i was i remember being so upset
i literally felt like i betrayed kobe
bryant sorry broski i literally felt
like i betrayed him
i was obsessed with kobe bryant i was
obsessed with kobe bryant
can i ask you a question okay um this
basketball related obviously
um first question before i go to my
follow-up question
do you mind me baiting out your surname
on this
my surname yeah of course not okay
now i can follow up now i can ask the
follow-up question so i already
feel like i know what you're gonna ask
me and i already have an answer for you
but go on
okay perfect then so remember back in
the day i'd say back in the day but
a few episodes ago appropriately 10 20
episodes ago you were talking about uh
midnight madness and now you can meet
how you almost met or you had the
potential to meet um
yeah how your goal was to be in the nba
but
did it ever cross your mind that people
would think that you may be related to
tim
um yes so much so
that when i was a kid when i said i
already have an answer for you and you
said surname yeah i just tell everyone
tim duncan was my uncle
i said lie to everyone and say tim
duncan's my uncle
because in england yeah if you're not a
basketball fan you ain't got a [ __ ]
clue who tim duncan is yeah yeah yeah
you ain't got a clue who tim duncan is
he's played for san antonio suppose
right yes but
yeah so in school i knew for a fact
no one knew who tim duncan was so when
people used to talk about basketball
there's a basketball that
i say yeah yeah bro and they'll be like
oh why you so into basketball why'd you
love basketball so much
and i was like bro i'm going to the nba
like my uncle i used to finesse the
whole thing but i'm going to nba just
like my uncle
and they're like uncle who knows like my
uncle tim bro
what are you talking about and he's
light-skinned as well
so no one this is when i was like yeah
yeah yeah no more smart enough to think
yeah no more smiles to think but your
dad's dark-skinned yeah
and that's supposed to be the brother i
don't think so but i'm like you know
what i thought it was i'm like skinny
same dunk because like
it pans and the face shape everything
you can if
you needed to believe bro it's
believable i used to tell everyone
yeah tindong's mind called that's a
letter from my uncle and they were like
nah it's not i was like
big man google him tim duncan's my uncle
i said you take one look at him and
you'll believe me
and they're like nah they're typing tim
duncan they're like oh [ __ ] is that your
uncle or somebody's uncle
for years for years bro i thought about
i think i thought about that question
after we spoke about that midnight
madness thing but it never came to mind
again
yeah bro for years i used to say that so
soon as you said
do you mind people knowing your surname
i was like i already know what you're
gonna say
okay and i've already got the answer
for years i told that lie that is
hilarious and the thing is i didn't even
check for tim duncan like that yeah yeah
yeah yeah
he was just a name he was a known name
he was a baller but he's a center
i can't relate to him yeah yeah yeah
yeah i don't know he was tall bro
total um anyway sorry the
naomi are succutting yes i've completely
forgotten the same
so naomi so that's the first bit that
cut me yes
the kobe bit the second part yeah
she um second part was
oh that was it about the olympics so
her whole career she said i want to be
the first asian woman to win a grand
slam
okay so whenever she comes out
obviously they say where you're from
yeah even though she is american
technically
she represents japan she always has okay
always guys just like djokovic slovenia
whatever
uh sabine slovakia i can't remember i
think is it slovakia
jungfish i can't remember but anyway
whoever comes out says where you're from
no matter what grandstand hers never
says usa
it always says japan it always has so
come push comes to shove now obviously
she's like
top ranked in the world yeah at this
point and then uh
olympics come around and everyone's
asking her are you gonna rep who are you
gonna rep usa
or um japan japan and um
peek how heisha doesn't even get a haiti
rather than hate he doesn't get a look
in bro
they would die to have her oh imagine
she represented haiti
wow yeah but anyway continue
so said japan or um usa which is what
it's going to be
and at the time she was um
doing a lot of uh of the blm protests
okay she's during blm times okay and um
she was repping a lot and she even
dropped out of a tournament one time
she just made it to the same she had a
semi-finals match okay in a grand i
think it was a grand slam tournament
i know it wasn't a grand slam tournament
it was a big tournament it wasn't a
grand slam grand slam okay um
and she she said i'm not playing um just
to draw attention and she had all these
masks
with like um like george floyd brianna
taylor all them
um and then when it came out
that um
she and then they said our olympics won
what's it going to be
she said i'm going to represent japan
fam she said
her own words she said her black card
got stripped
as soon as she said she's not doing the
osa she's doing japan
done bro she got so much hay
from uh us people even though she's been
ripping japan her
whole career and i was thinking
supporters of athletics in all forms and
sports
are so entitled yeah it makes me sick
yeah they actually think athletes are
property
yeah same way with the euros or just
about to compare it to the euro
exactly that's why i brought the whole
thing up exactly the same as euros yeah
they think people are their property
yeah and when their their property is
not doing as it's told
done with you done you're useless to me
done with you bro she said she got
as soon as she said she's repping japan
they were like get
[ __ ] like you're not even black go
go away like we have no interest in you
hey that big man i'll be ripping japan
from day no one had an issue
until you're looking for who's the best
person to represent you in the olympics
and i'm number one now you're vex if i
was
ranked 115th you wouldn't give a single
thing
flying [ __ ] who i'm representing
it's um it's a crazy world we live in
man
it's a crazy everyone wants to be the
best but everyone also wants to
represent the person that is the best
of course it's a crazy world we live in
modern when you're winning you're
you're god and you own your own has got
a god if you're doing justice
for the team that you're supposed to be
doing justice for this is saying um
you know who ursula's master ozil yeah
he's a footballer that used to play for
real madrid and then arsenal
he plays for i think somewhere in turkey
now correct me if i'm wrong but he's a
he was a german international he doesn't
play for germany anymore
but when he was playing and winning for
germany he used to say oh when i win for
germany or when i win
i'm german when i'm not i'm exiled or
something like that and it's like
and that's the reason why he denounced
the plane for germany yeah it's like
that's understandable bro
that's [ __ ] understandable man same
thing obviously with the euros like you
said
with rashford sancho and saka like it's
um
[Music]
it's a tough thing to have to know that
if i score i'm a hero if i miss
i'm a villain oh
[ __ ] villain because of the color of
my skin
it's mad it's mad bro
and the thing is it's not the thing is
the joke of it is is that it's got
nothing to do with the color of their
skin
they would regardless if they're black
or not things people will focus on the
racing
which obviously is the main focus but
for ignorant [ __ ] that's just the
easiest thing to say yeah yeah it's the
easy thing to pick on
because if it was kane that missed yeah
if everyone else scored
and harry kane missed he would be
getting exactly the same amount of hate
obviously they wouldn't be calling him
whiteness or like that but they would
find something
to make him feel like the scum of the
[ __ ] earth if he was the sole reason
why we lost
but obviously if you're black it's easy
it's easier
it's easier bro you're a monkey it's
easy
but obviously the race i'm not trying to
diminish the fact that they were
racially abused i'm not trying to say
that i'm just saying
athletes as a whole as an entire
unity athletes are as a whole get
treated like [ __ ]
when they're not winning yeah they get
treated like absolute [ __ ]
um even when they are winning same thing
with anthony joshua he came out long
long long ago and said big man these
times i'm trying to rep nigeria
because these dons in the uk they do not
check for me
i've done nothing wrong and all i get is
hate yeah hate bro
all i get is hate like i i might as well
just say i'm nigerian from now on
and say [ __ ] britain britain especially
bro we're the worst for it yeah
we are the [ __ ] worst foreign
agreed we are the worst agreed the same
men that were
that were racially abusing like back in
the day probably like two three years
ago racially abusing sterling are the
same and that cheered for him because he
scored the first three goals in the
tournament yeah
for the for england they were the same
man that were cheering him yeah yeah
same with the papers like the sun or
daily mail it's just oh he's not human
he's property he's property he's english
property bro
same thing with andy murray he's
scottish when he's losing he's scottish
he's going when he's
winnie's british disgusting
crazy bro crazy
this is a game you know it's actually a
game literally is a game
it's a game and the game isn't for us we
are privileged to watch it
they're the one playing it's their game
it's these 11 man versus these 11 man
it's their thing we have nothing to do
with it
but we're so entitled that's the word
we're so entitled
we own this game and we own you man and
we need bragging rights
for [ __ ] against countries that we're
never gonna visit
we need bragging rights it's coming home
home but we've seen the thing
we've seen the thing since the 60s home
ah bro
livid it's a crazy world we live in man
it is a crazy world and i hate it
is and i think i think you've said this
before
on here but obviously can't remember
which episode the only way we can tackle
this kind of problem in terms of
um like this racial status quo is if
or is once everyone mixes with everyone
like there's interracial couples and
relationships everywhere everyone's
brown
everyone's that's the only everyone's
brown everyone's battle yeah everyone's
back that's the only way [ __ ] can pan
yeah it's true bro because the diversity
that we're living in at the moment i
think it's
i don't think it's at its peak but it's
bubbling it's there you know
it's there so i feel like once everyone
just starts
integrating with everyone and obviously
when i say interracial i don't just mean
black versus white or black and white
because
that's i think that's the most common
interracial kind of thing you think of
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
interracial could mean [ __ ] japanese
and chinese
yeah there's two different races so but
in that context
i feel like that's the only way people
can actually just be like
okay cool he's one of us yeah and then
regardless win or lose
he's still one of us you know thing is
as well though like
the dread thing is about it is that what
i think what a lot of people miss
sometimes
is that you are right in that once
everyone's brown
there should there'll be no more like
racism
but there'll always be tribalism
and racism is just an extended version
of tribalism
people so it's our human nature
to to have clicks we need to feel like
it's in our dna that we need to feel
like we belong to
somewhere yes agreed agreement this is
our click and
other people are an issue agreed i know
what you mean rather other countries are
an issue are there racism races are an
issue
like there's the workers and the bosses
there's this and there's that yeah
there's left and there's right yeah
and we need literally tribalism
like that's basically what the olympics
is is
these tribes all the tribes come
together and go against each other
and you support your tribe and [ __ ]
everyone else
[ __ ] everyone else um and
you'll only support the tribes that
belong to you so even you even fight i
even found myself doing it
when i was watching the opening ceremony
i was watching all these countries come
out
bro great britain let's go
trinidad let's go grenada let's go
oh you man come ireland let's go all
these men are cool the rest is man can
[ __ ] do one like they need to get
smacked up and even to the point where
you're watching something
and the sales watching the skateboarding
the other day yeah you've got add usa
france italy usa france italy and peru
[Music]
usa france italy peru and
brazil they were in the finals
the closest tribe out of all of them to
me is usa mm-hmm
i mean team usa yeah yeah i'm team usa i
feel among you
you need to fill among you need to feel
you need to belong to somewhere yeah
yeah
in something yeah in everything yeah so
even if i feel like
even rick and morty did it best when
um they had the race wars from the
spiral nipples to the cone nipples do
you remember
yes yes yes yes when they
when um when rick was doing a thing with
the planet with the planet
yeah yeah
india you've got dark skin versus light
skin they're all [ __ ] indian
no one gives a [ __ ] when they come over
to england i don't see who's like skinny
who's dark skinned you're either indian
or you're not yeah like
it doesn't matter to me but if you go
over there they find their way to
to separate casts yeah they find their
way to do these things
it's always going to happen even when
the whole world is brown people are
always going to be tribalists
and they're going to find a way to to
find a click and [ __ ] everything else
so racism may diminish but they'll find
something else
which is just human nature um but
obviously i'm not excusing racism but
i'm just saying i don't think
separation will ever stop i hear you bro
i don't think it would ever stop i hear
you man i think people will always find
a way to
[ __ ] off someone else it's an excuse at
the end of the day hmm
it is what it is you have the middle
class the working class the upper class
like you've got
everything all these things it's like
when yes you break it down all of these
things are just tribes yeah
all of them are tribes oh i connect with
this person because we
have similar interests we grew up in
similar environments and stuff like that
tribes
like you don't feel comfortable in
someone else's tribe that's basically
what it boils down to because when you
think about it
like say if you're looking for a partner
you're like oh we have some of similar
values and
all this stuff and like like your
parents like oh
my mom will be so happy if i go with a
nigerian but if i can't get with a
nigerian she'll be content if i go with
someone who's from ghana yeah you know
what i mean
tribes yeah yeah yeah yeah i can't bring
a number white girl that's a different
tribe fan
that can't run yeah i know everything it
always boils down to something yeah
and um people don't like examine on a
day-to-day basis you wouldn't
but it always it will always come down
to something always
speaking of what you just said about my
parents and stuff well not specifically
my parents but i know what you meant
um that's one of the main reasons why
i'm happy the way i am in terms of
obviously spoken about the in the
previous episode about like religion and
stuff about how my parents were
like cultivating that that's all they
knew and obviously my whole family is my
my whole immediate family is muslim etc
and their parents were muslim above so
on and so forth i'm happy that
i've kind of broken the cycle yeah even
though it's hard for me
because people don't people don't
necessarily know that i think about
i obviously want my parents to be happy
and i also want my parents to be proud
of me yeah yes
um but i also want to live my own life
and my own truth
yeah but it's also hard to it's hard to
do both yeah
because they brought me into this world
and i know they always want the best for
me and they always try and advise me
for them to they always advise me so
they can
be sure that i'm doing the best for
myself but if i do something that's
not within their realm of comprehension
they think it's a negative thing yeah of
course but it's also hard
to just try and tell them that big man
you've lived you're like this is me you
know
this is me i'm not one try if i get
married to someone that's not nigerian
or not ghanaian i'm not black even
it's my marriage big man do you want me
to be happy or do you want you to be
happy
yeah you know exactly and what is and
what is even you being happy what does
that even
equate to what does your happiness in
this situation mean
because once the wedding is over you
don't give a [ __ ] anymore
you literally don't give a [ __ ] it's all
show-and-tell it's all show and tell you
you just want to tell your brethrens
once your bridges have been told
you forget you will have fun
my parents don't my parents don't
remember my sister's wedding in terms of
like
who was there i don't know yeah they
were just there for
obviously they weren't there for the
facade of it but yes they were it was it
was just one of them ones where she was
they were proud
yeah yeah yeah but once i remember it
obviously but once once it's done it's
done
bro and it's just like it's a tough
world we live in man
it's a tough one to be living but also
it just shows how
older generations have passed things
down onto younger generations
and the younger generations that adapt
that and continue to think of that old
mentality
will force that onto their kids whereas
people like me for example that are
broken out of that cycle
i'm happy i've broken out that cycle but
it's also hard to
live my truth knowing how much i still
want to not necessarily impress but
make my parents proud exactly and you
want to make your parents proud
and on top of that
you also have situations in which when
you say like it's trickled down
so obviously this is triggered down from
your parents so you decide
i want to be an a i don't want to be an
outlier but it's just who i am
so you step out to the side but then
so if we step back to the tribalism
thing again you've got all these
nigerians
yeah all of them moved to uk so we've
got the nigerian tribe and they all have
kids
yeah all of these kids are british yeah
and then you've got that's one thing
they forget
that's one thing they [ __ ] forget
they didn't ask to be born here
you know yeah they forget that i'm born
in this
what's the word multicultural
multicultural melting pot they forget
that yeah yeah yeah yeah but sorry
continue
no you it's true bro they do forget so
they have all of these they take all the
nigerian values
and it's not not just nigerians
caribbean is everything but that's
exactly
example yeah they bring all their
nigerian values to
england yeah they have a nigerian
society they have a muslim society a
catholic society christian site whatever
and they have kids and they instill with
those kids all of their values
those kids are british and they grow up
british but they have nigerian values
people like you step out to the side and
you guys are the outliers
but you relate so much to being a like
second generation
nigerian that you make friends with all
the other second generation nigerians of
course
because you feel a monk you feel like
you're hungry of course right
this is your [ __ ] tribe yeah yeah
yeah all of them agree you man can bust
joke about
oh mom where can i put my shoes put them
on my head all of this [ __ ] that you and
jacob [ __ ] didn't even know each
other
yeah all your lives and you you say
sentence for sentence the same [ __ ] same
[ __ ]
so you have all of this but then
what makes it worse is that you when you
come out of it and you do a thing with a
white girl or an asian girl or whatever
you get pressure from your parents so
that's outside of the tribe and that's
negative
you need to hope that this group of
second generation nigerians
are also outliers which sometimes
they're not
of course not sometimes they're not and
then
you get stick probably not from the guys
but definitely from the girls
hundred percent you only like white
girls because they have nigerian values
and they're all about this tribe thing
as well so you're an outlier so you're
getting negative from here
and negative from here which just ruins
everything
yeah and it's just unnecessary pressure
yeah for whatever reasons and then
you've got a couple of your boys
that are like whatever yeah like they're
like you yeah and obviously i've met
some of your boys and stuff that they
are he's literally exactly like you yeah
and it's just like why should i have so
much pressure just to live my life yeah
it's watching my life i shouldn't ever
have to take into consideration
someone's skin color
racial beliefs or upbringing into the
kind of person that i want to spend time
with
yeah or spend my life with or think
about i can do a thing with this girl i
can even live with this girl
but it's long if i want to marry you
yeah it's just long to the point where
you might even be put off marrying them
because you're like i just don't want to
deal with the hassle mm-hmm so what is
that
what literally is that
it's long literal definition bro it's
actually long and a lot of the time the
only way you can get out of it
is to double down on being an outlier
and said [ __ ] off like i'm gonna do what
i want
you have a kid with a white girl you
then have black kids
who have such a disconnect from their
nigerian heritage because their nigerian
heritage is so stuck in their old ways
that you don't even want to expose them
to that yeah so all they know is the
other side
and all they know is the other side and
then you're disappointed that your kids
know [ __ ] all about their heritage
yeah it's um it's a backwards cycle mum
it's long um
it's long bro it's actually long
wow that took a turn it did take a time
reality
don't be sorry because reality purely
because it's not this is not the first
time i've thought about things like this
you know i think about this
not more often than not but it pops into
my mind you know yeah
because i think i don't know if i've
said it on here but i probably
definitely said it to you that i'm
probably not gonna marry a nigerian
oh yeah of course you said it yeah yeah
so it's like
what's next you know yeah where do i go
from here yeah
it's hard because everything you've just
said is my reality
it's long it's my reality brother and
it's tough
it's tough bro especially especially
as i said in previous episode i've got
an example like my sister
because that's what my parents doubled
down on yeah yeah she's the golden child
she's the golden child she's a muslim
married and muslim married i'm nigerian
muslim yeah
they've got kids together they've done
everything the way they would have
wanted to do it
yeah i eat my parents yeah you know yeah
so i in their eyes i'm just an outsider
even though they know i'm not yeah but
if we're speaking figuratively yeah your
boy is an outsider
and it hurts bro it's tough breaking my
heart it's tough my all jokes aside you
literally breaking my heart it's tough
i think about this more often than not
it's hard life is hard bro life is hard
when
ancestors and asian beliefs and ancient
religions and
things like that get passed on and
you as a man don't accept it or you as a
woman don't accept that and you try to
live your own truth in your own life
it's oh it's just tough bro
yeah because you you come against
resistance
you come against resistance and like you
said like especially like you as a
person you don't like disappointing
people
i try not to yeah you intentionally try
not to disappoint people so then you get
yourself stressed
about the life choices you're making
which will then trickle down into your
relationships
because similar to what you've had in
relationship in the past that obviously
we won't go to details before
but both of you came from that
environment separately
and you both came to it like where is
this even gonna go
where we can't get married where is this
actually gonna go because us
these sides aren't gonna marry up so we
might as well like it now
that should never be the case it should
never ever ever be the case but this is
the world we live in my dream
and it's tough because yes this is the
world be living by it makes it seem as
if
my parents are making my choices for me
oh yeah
i'm 30 years old bro i hear you bro
i'm a full-fledged adult
bro i'm with you but yeah it does
trickle down bro even
it even triggers down further than not
even further than that but
you have examples like myself this is
nowhere near i'm not even trying to
compare it to you
but like subconscious choices that i
make in my life
like i knew when i was in year seven
year seven that i didn't want to have a
baby with a white girl
okay because i didn't want my kids to be
white okay
i'm not even thinking about stuff like
that back then bro
oh wow that's what i used to think about
oh wow because
because i i thought about it in terms of
just into like like i said obviously you
wouldn't think about stuff like that but
because i know i'm
one kid away from there being no black
anymore yeah
okay and i'm yeah so like i knew from
when i was younger
like i enjoyed being mixed race so
it's not like i wanted to take the brown
and turn it back into black
but i just wanted to be there more of me
and um when i was younger
i was just like i don't think i can have
a baby of a white girl
because then i'm going to have like a
white baby and if that baby has a baby
with a white girl or a white guy
that's it that's right duncan's aren't
black anymore
literally duncan's won't be black
anymore no offense to my brother i know
he's having a baby white girl
i know for a fact he is um if he ever
has a baby i don't think my kid brother
even wants kids but
um like i knew out of all my family
if anyone's keeping that alive keeping
the black in there it's going to be me
yeah yeah yeah
so i've known since i was a kid yeah
that like there's pressure on me
yeah for this family to stay black yeah
because it's it's a it's a hopper skip
and a jump away from not being black
anymore yeah
now that's it we got deep mum
bro we got deep quick yeah yeah it
actually got deep quick yeah mum
out of nowhere i don't even think we can
do a miley [ __ ] i don't think not
under these circumstances
these circumstances i don't think we can
oh jesus i think we might have to just
wrap it up there
let's rapidly wrap bro yeah yeah yeah
yeah all right we love you guys
thank you if you managed to make it this
far thank you very much
thank you um we'll see in a couple days
we'll see in a couple days
love
[Music]
you